الأطفال يبتسمون في
عمق صدماتهم ، المدرسة هي واحدة من الرجال الذين
يؤويون النازحين الموسيقى الصاخبة التي
تغرق مؤقتًا
أصوات الانفجارات على خط المواجهة على
بعد 15 دقيقة فقط بالسيارة حتى في
سنهم الصغير وهم يعرفون أن الموت يمكن أن
يأتي  في لحظة تحاول
فيها الاستمتاع
بإبقاء وزنها على قدمها المصابة بحذر شديد ،
كنت أتناول تفاحة مع
أختي ثم أصابنا الصاروخ ،
تتذكر أنني نظرت ولم أستطع سوى رؤية
الغبار ، وحدثت تلك الضربة قبل أسبوع
في المدرسة  في الجوار
حيث كانت عائلة الفأس مع
آخرين يعيشون ، سقط صاروخ في
ساحة المدرسة مما أسفر عن مقتل سبعة
أطفال وإصابة كثيرين آخرين ، لكن بينما
يظهر لنا الأب قدمها المغطاة بالضمادات ، فإن
ابنته لا تزال على قيد الحياة وهي تتألم من
الطريقة التي من المفترض أن يحميها
لقد اعتدت على سماع أصوات
ارتطام الطائرات ، ولكن منذ أن
أصابنا خوف من ذلك
[موسيقى]
قاموا بتدريب الأطفال على ما
يجب عليهم فعله إذا  تقترب انفجارات الأذن أو
القصف بحيث يكون أحدهما ملجأ في
مكانه ثم الآخر على الرغم من
اتباع السهم المرسوم على الجدران
للذهاب نحو المخبأ ،
فهو ليس مخبأًا حقيقيًا فقط غرفة
تحت الأرض كانت تستخدم لتخزين
الغبار الآن مغطى  كتب مدرسية السماء
خارج البلدة
ملطخة بخطوط الطائرات المقاتلة في الساعات الأولى
من صباح اليوم التالي دمرت مزرعة دجاج
كانت تستخدم لإيواء النازحين ، مما
أدى إلى تدمير العديد من أولئك الذين
احتموا هناك أثناء نومهم بما في ذلك
الأطفال ، والمستشفيات غارقة في
التعامل ليس فقط  بالأمراض
والمرض ولكن التدفق المستمر
للجرحى لا توجد حرمة هنا على
الأقل بالنسبة للحياة المدنية في الشهر الماضي ، زادت
تركيا من تدخلها العسكري
وضرب مواقع النظام.
الشباب
الذين كانوا في المدرسة الثانوية عندما
تحولت الثورة السورية إلى حقيقة
الوجود التركي يمنع
النظام من التقدم  على الأرض ،
يقول أبو سعود ، 26 عامًا ، إن معركتنا
تدور حول الدفاع عن السكان ، زوجتي ،
أطفالي ، لكن كيف أحمي
هؤلاء السكان حقًا ، فليس في الواقع تحت
سيطرة هؤلاء المقاتلين ، إنه في تركيا ،
وأيدي روسيا هما القوتان الرئيسيتان اللتان
تقايضان مصيرهما.  بغض النظر عن
ما تم التفاوض عليه ، كان هناك
الكثير من الوعود ، الكثير من حرائق وقف إطلاق النار المكسورة ،
الكثير من الاتفاقيات الوهمية تطارد الألم في
كل شارع ، مات ابنه
هنا ، يا له من مكب نفايات كان أنا
محمد في الثانية عشرة من عمره ،
أخبرنا أخوه الأكبر أنهم ركضوا عندما رأوا
الطائرة  لكن محمد لم يجعل الأمر
جينومًا لداعش ، فقد لا تحاول
حمله ، لكن لم أستطع أن أرى
يتذكر أن محمد مات بين ذراعيه حتى
الاحتفالات كانت حلوة ومر
هؤلاء النساء يتسوقن لفساتين
زفاف أقاربهن لكنها فازت.  ستكون
علاقة فخمة ، إنها ليست نوع من
السعادة حيث تقوم بدعوة كل
شخص تخبرنا أخت العريس أنه سيكون
صغيرًا مع العائلة المباشرة ، فهناك
الكثير من البؤس والخوف  أن حشدًا كبيرًا
سيتعرض للقصف منذ ديسمبر / كانون الأول
، نزح حوالي مليون شخص
محشورين في أي مساحة فارغة يمكنهم
العثور عليها حتى في هذا السجن ، تنام العائلات هنا
بملابسهم دون أن يعرفوا
متى قد يحتاجون إلى نفاد المارينز
، قُتل والد المارينز في القتال منذ سنوات
يسخر دانيال من أي شيء اعتاد أن
يلعب معنا كثيرًا عندما كان على قيد الحياة ، تتذكر
عندما نغادر ما يُعرف
بمخيم المقبرة لأنه حتى الموتى
تم تهجيرهم مدفونين
بالقرب من الحدود مع تركيا
على أمل  أنه على الأقل يمكنهم أن يرقد
بسلام
أروى دامون CNN إنها تعيش سوريا